gloria thank you so much well this
possible case is bringing more attention
to the virus right here in southern
nevada now we spoke to one medical
expert today about how concerned our
community should be and what steps we
can take to protect ourselves
i think the best way is just trying to
avoid being exposed in the first place
right now dr david dijon says residents
should keep an eye out for any monkey
pox symptoms on their body just these
kind of pustular rather large looking
lesions
although sometimes they can be smaller
and look more like blisters or what we
call vesicles
but if you have other features as well
like
fever headache body aches dr dijon says
although monkey pox is not highly
contagious this virus spreads by direct
contact with an infected person hand
sanitizer he says is always a great tool
to have as the virus it can show up
anywhere they can really appear anywhere
on the body on the face
on the extremities
oftentimes if you have direct contact
especially with an infected animal you
may get the lesions on your hands the
name monkey pox comes from the first
discovery of the virus with the animal
according to dr dejean
20 years ago he says a large outbreak of
monkey pox took place across multiple
states his suggestion practice good
hygiene resolution takes days to weeks
for
symptoms and and the
eruption to to resolve supportive care
treatment
well again dr dijon says there is no
need to panic because there is treatment
and even vaccines if needed now you
heard him talk about the virus spreading
through infected people or animals so we
asked for those of us with pets if we if
we should be concerned he said right now
it's too early to tell